okay so I wanted to share with you a
cool trick that I came across it helps
save money we bring in their labeling
stage using clustering as the name
suggests this is the problem we are
facing we have a law firm that has a lot
of contracts but they are not labeled
and what the law firm wants to achieve
is to be able to classify all of those
documents into one with three clusters a
B or C one of the classes a B or C now
labeling a contract is not cheap because
lawyers aren't cheap and a lawyer needs
to read the contract in order to label
it on the upside contracts are very
similar to one another so lawyers love
the copy-paste but between us so let's
try and take advantage of this fact this
is the idea first we try to cluster
contracts together then we try to take
one example from each cluster and let
our expensive loyal label it and then
saving money so the first stage we need
to take is to take a document a contract
and convert it in some magical way into
a vector now there are a lot of ways to
do this the most simple one is just to
count how many words are in each
document and then you have this large
vector the size of the vocabulary other
most sophisticated ways for example
tf-idf also account for the frequency of
words maybe words like they're off and
aren't as informative as other words I
don't methods there are a lot of neural
networks method I don't want to
elaborate more on this just you need to
have a method to take your contract take
a document and convert it into a vector
this is a free liner in s Calum that
does tf-idf for you if you only want to
count then use the first two lines very
easy
very
next we want to cluster all of those
vectors that we built together now
usually when people think about
clustering they think about k-means
k-means is a top-down approach meaning
that you assign K clusters K centroids
and then you shake them and move them
around in some magical way and at the
end you get a division of the space into
K clusters the other approach is called
bottom-up you start with n clusters and
being the number of documents and then
you start to melt them together
according to distance one by one at the
end of this process you need to decide
when to stop what is the minimal
distance that is still the important you
get a variant number of clusters this is
how you do a vertical clustering in
Python pretty simple Sify has a very
easy implementation for it
erricka clustering has three hyper
parameters the first is what distance do
you use a lot of choices inside pipe
next is what is the minimal distance
that that you need to account for the
minimal distance that you still consider
things to be in the same cluster this is
called the cutoff distance and the last
hyper parameter is where do you measure
the distance from do you measure it from
the center of the cluster do you measure
it from the bound from the fit for the
farthest point once we decided on an
embedding method and the clustering
algorithm we have a clustering and now
we want to evaluate it so there are a
lot of ways to evaluate cluster
clustering algorithms in the general
sense but in this context we want to
find the best cluster that will help us
label the data so a neat way to look at
the clustering algorithm is in this
table in this table we ask the loyal to
label a small sample of
the documents and then we saw how a
clustering algorithm works on this on
the label data for example in the first
table we can see that cluster one is two
two items two documents that are labeled
as a cluster to his tool a birthday is
two items labeled as B and so on and
what we wanted to achieve we have two
objectives that we want to optimize for
one is that we want as little clusters
as possible because the more clusters
the more work our lawyer needs to do and
thus we pay more the second one that we
want as little collisions or no
collisions as possible for example here
blaster one has two types of labels
which means that one of those the labels
are going to be mislabeled and then our
model gonna going to suffer from this
issue next regarding results so we
applied this method on 35,000 documents
and we were very picky regarding we
didn't want any labeling error and we
got a 50% reduction in in labels so 50%
less money and we overlapping it runs in
a matter of minutes or less depending on
your data but it's not something that
you need to run overnight and you can
see here that actually the clusters make
sense so this is only like 13 all those
all those crimes all those closes
actually talked about the same thing to
talk about counterpart so whatever legal
mumbo-jumbo okay to summarize see enough
to have to do hierarchical clustering in
Python using standard sci-fi and SK
learn the hyper parameters you need to
play with how do you embed with your
data how do you obey the document how do
you convert documents to a vector how do
you measure distance and what is the
cutoff where do we measure distance from
how to evaluate that true objective that
you can optimize for depending on how it
was sensitive you are labeled how
sensitive your labeling is and we
achieved 50% reduction without
sacrificing any accuracy questions so I
don't understand the evaluation process
do you have a where do you get the
labels from lawyers talk all the
documents in the cluster so it's
evaluation in perspective we have to ask
the lawyer to take a small sample so we
know who in dissent within the right
direction just to repeat the question
yes the question was how do we get the
labeled data from because if you have
the label data then this whole exercise
is meaningless so we ask our loyal to
10% or even less then we can evaluate
+20 algorithms and choose the quiz so
the question was well we have a label
data let's just just train classifiers
and then you write the classic day
clustering algorithm from that so
actually we might cover just a small
sample of all of potential labels that
we might have or potential for example
let's say that we have 10,000 types of
classes and Appell only have 5000 so
it's better it's best just to make sure
that what we can see not making any
mistakes rather than 20 classifiers in
advance other questions so the question
was how do I know that the clustering is
is good if I first cluster and then ask
a lawyer to Dennis the loyal to label it
so for only for evaluation purposes
which is important I ask the lawyer to
classify 10% of the data or even less
and then using that 10% of the data I
adjust my class knowing I'll go
Thank You Olli my name is Omri I work
for data scientist at Intel starting
next month I am a data scientist at
Microsoft
I'll be talking about how to leverage
ideas from functional programming not
the entire thing but just some ideas
when we're doing data manipulation in
Python and pandas first of all what is
functional programming in a nutshell so
in a nutshell it's about using functions
obviously functions that are pure they
don't have any side-effects
it means that every function that we use
doesn't change anything outside the
function and it's not dependent on
anything outside the function
declarative versus imperative means that
we declarative programming means that we
focus on what's going on and know and
not how its implemented so if you know
SQL or sequel it's a good example of
declarative programming we don't
implement the where clause we just say
where and and at the language speaks for
itself that's it's a usually easier to
read and even in non functional
programming languages there is some
support of this notion so for example
Scala has this kind of API Java has the
streaming function api's in starting
from Java 8 in our everybody started
using packages like deployer which is
more functional than the base are in
dotnet c-sharp there is language
integrated querying and obviously sequel
is one example so let's take a look at
three chunks of code that actually do
the same thing the one would usually
usually go down on this path so the code
is supposed to tell a story other than
just solve the problem and when we do
our data pipeline we usually do
something like this so we take some data
set and we send it to a function get the
result send it to the to the next
function so on so forth usually it's a
lot more Messier it's usually it's like
hundreds of lines and the
guy that has to write to read the code
after us is a miserable this is another
more extreme extreme example where we
send every function as an argument to
the other it's actually the same code
and I would argue that this this
approach which is a little not it's not
very high sonic I guess is easier to
read and if there is a problem with it
I'd intended intention here but
basically this are the operator is is is
piping so we take our dataset we pipe it
to the next method with some argument
and then we pipe it to the to the next
one and so on so forth and if we try to
read the story of Jack and Jill then
it's just in front of our face Jack and
Jill went up the hill to fetch some
water etc so we talked about how it's
going how it's working in other
languages and let's take an example from
deep fryer I know people don't like our
but it's a good example so our head the
notion of data frames Allah before
Python did and people used it and it was
fine until deep liar was released and
then people started using deep layer and
never looked back basically
so in deep layer you use all kinds of
verbs such as select filter arrange
there are people usually know them from
SQL and you create a data flow through
piping another great feature of deep
layer is the ability to seamlessly
replace your back-end so the code is not
really running in our you could actually
send it to to an SQL server or to spark
or to bigquery and you can basically
change the backend with a change of
configuration without having to change
the code itself so as an example we take
a data set we pipe it to maybe a
function that we wrote ourselves and
then to the words that deep area offers
us and we get the final product here so
we're not here to talk about ours
so let's look on one approach do this in
Python it's just one approach you could
do it in many many ways the package is
called DF ply it's a Python
implementation of deep liar it's built
on top of pandas so you could use it
with pandas interchangeably
and in many cases it's just a wrapper up
on top of pandas it's a work in progress
it's not completely mature but again
it's just one option that you could use
so I'm importing DF ply and I'm calling
diamonds okay so not used to to a Mac so
instead of calling diamonds dot head I'm
piping diamonds into a head and I get
the head of diamonds diamond to the data
set of diamonds with the different
attributes obviously to select a column
I pipe diamonds into the selectors and I
could either call X dot name of column
or the index of the column or a string
with the column name and I get the
result so the syntax is in my opinion a
little better than what pandas
originally supports to filter out a set
of Records
i pipe diamonds into masks where the cut
is ideal the color is e and the price is
lower than 500 okay and I could go on
using other verbs such as mutate which
actually creates new columns I could use
functions like league-leading lat lead
and lag I could do different types of
joins and it's basically a different
syntax it's it's you could achieve the
same thing with pandas but maybe the
syntax here is is nicer window functions
so I group by and for every group I
calculate the lead in the lag of some
variable and if we compare the syntax of
this package with with native pandas
then in these two examples we do the
same thing we group I and we summarize
we look at every group at some statistic
of every group and you could just see if
which which interface is better for you
but this is the same idea to use just in
in pandas okay so key takeaways is that
if we even if even if we are not using
this DF by package or just taking some
ideas from functional programming and
we're you we're doing
atomic functions that are pure we are
able to use the code again we're
building a set of tools for ourselves
it's much easier to unit tests because
we have a function with only that
doesn't interact with with outside
environment so it's easier to unit test
it the readability of the code is
usually better in my opinion you could
just start piping your date your your
flow and see if some point at some point
there is a problem with scalability and
then drill down and see if you can
improve on the code under the hood in
deep layer you could replace the back
end and good news is that pandas to
actually do this for us so starting from
pandas - we will be able to get better
back and support and because the verbs
are quite similar between environments
then if you have to migrate your code
from Python to a different environment
and it's usually easier so that's it
thanks question usually the same it
might because it evaluates differently
it might be a might be different from
pandas but again try it and see if it
works for you then okay if not me you
can always go back to the original
pandas is it supports a kind of a
pipeline object like we have been
implanted sometimes or like for feature
extraction stuff like can I save it is a
pipe in a way I'm not sure if it does
it's I don't think it does this package
maybe there are other alternatives too
okay hey everyone I really like this
short talks format so having me
my name is Jay I'm the head of data
science at windward we do some kind of
maritime AI stuff trying to get insights
from what's happening on the oceans but
you're not gonna hear about it today so
if you want to talk to me about it feel
free we're also hiring so when I started
to think of what I want to present I
thought maybe I should talk about this
beautiful plotly dashboards or maybe
give you some tips of how to profile
your code and using Jupiter notebook
visualization like snake vase but then
then I thought thought to myself why
give you something practical when I can
talk on whatever I would like to so I'm
going to talk about something totally
not technical of how to become an
impactful data scientist short survey
how many of you found themselves doing
work that they thought was insignificant
to their business like what am i doing
that's that's very few people good for
you on the other hand how many people
found the safe doing like trying to
solve a problem that was really
significant for their business like oh
so I want I want to push for it what's
the second side of the spectrum let's
talk about a little bit about motivation
why impactful is good so the obvious
thing is if you if you are influential
you're gonna get paid and you're gonna
be valued to great things but I think
the most important thing is that we like
to do stuff that matters okay we are
sitting in eight nine hours in front of
a computer we wanted to move to make to
move to count right so this is for me
the most
the main motivation so what I'm talking
here you all know these Venn diagrams of
data scientists skills and stuff so what
I'm suggesting is to maybe even demand
more of ourselves in terms of business
understanding it is related to the
domain expertise area but it's not
really the same thing but that's that's
like the the direction of this talk
a few practical things that you can do
to be more impactful so first you must
understand the context in business needs
in the military it's always advisable to
know like two levels above you right if
you are
platoon commander you need to know
what's happening in the company and the
battalion level so if we take the
analogy to the tech world you need to
understand what's not happening in not
only in your team but entire island a
group or them close at sixty people
you're working with and you need to be
brave enough to ask questions both I
don't know your team leader product guys
not like not being like the annoying
kind of data scientist but really trying
to understand why is this important why
are we doing this and not that and try
to really understand the motivation your
your work will be much more guided if
you do so in order to do it you need to
get out of your bubble
most of us sit in our laptops in our
corner you really need to start talking
with other people in startups it's
really easy you go and you talk to the
product the guys the sales guys maybe
even a clients but you can do you can do
it also in larger organizations talk to
other groups try to understand what what
what sells ok it's really important to
get to get the general idea and you can
also make some useful allies along the
way we're not playing playing the game
of thrones here but these guys can help
you push for your initiatives I will get
back to it in a few minutes one thing
that is often overlooked is planning the
the project the data science solution I
explicitly wrote a data science solution
here because we're not building a model
we're not trying to win a kegel
competition we're trying to answer a
business need and sometimes these first
critical stages of often overlooked
feeling like a rock star so so basically
you need to understand what you're
trying to solve
you need to plot a mock like a simple
graph how the solution would look like
even on a piece of paper you need to
understand what the metric you you you
need to optimize not just run and build
features
okay in the book of thinking with data
science they have this acronym of convo
you need to understand the context the
need the vision and the outcome of how
the solution would look like and it's
recommended to start thinking in this in
this way you it's very important to
understand trade-offs what is more
important precision or recall is just
one one kind of trade-off you can start
and another thing that I urge you to do
is not to be afraid to start with simple
solutions okay don't say like oh me
decision tree I don't do this Asian tree
it's like this stupid model but it's
more interpret but it's easy to debug a
decision tree at the beginning right
maybe don't even start with machine
learning just try a simple heuristic
gather data trying to understand try to
understand if you are solving the
problem very advisable reading is rules
of ml of Martinez think of it from
Google the best 25 pages you can read on
building machine learning solutions very
recommended one one more thing I'd like
to I'd like to suggest you to start a
side project we all know Google 20% and
not every company is Google so but my
experience is that basically innovation
doesn't come from yearly yearly plans or
quarterly product plans peoples you know
hear great ideas and they want to
implement them they have like insights
and and you need to push for it your
your good ideas don't tell your boss I
need a day a week some people some
managers can be afraid of it but try and
say I have this idea when a few hours a
week like an hours of every day to work
on it really you will get the support
you need you need four things that will
make your efforts more focused so first
it needs to be interesting because you
are the only one that cares about this
project so if you don't like it no one
as will the second thing it needs to be
doable
don't start building massive
infrastructure it has to be something
that you can do with existing tools it
usually happens that a new tool is added
and then new capabilities and new ideas
come along with it so it needs to be
doable
it needs to be impactful don't try to
him just to improve the tiny bit of of
existing a solution because no one would
care and it also needs to provide value
pretty pretty early on no one who let a
year to see or to see your results and
it is very important to understand that
you are not building a product here
you're building a POC you're building
something that will create enough
traction and curiosity within the
organization and people say well that's
this is this is cool let's put some real
effort into it and put it into a product
when what we had a couple of successes
of people of doing their side projects
and pushing them and they became they
became really meaningful parts of the
project
of the product that's about side project
you also need to publish your work we
usually stop well once you we solve the
analytical problem you usually stop
caring or it's less interesting for us
but it's really important to get
feedback and engagement out of other
people in the organization you need to
invest in tutorials documentation API is
especially for non-technical people and
it's really important to talk to the
allies you made on section number two
and ask for their opinion if no one uses
your internal tool for example you need
to understand why it's very important to
get feedback on early stages of your
work so do do like off product review
mint of parts of the of your solution
about this software generic things how
many of you learned software engineering
university or something okay so more
than half didn't I read vies you to get
like para de paradigms am so like get a
few ideas that will make your work much
more efficient each one of them is like
an hours of lecturing but code reuse was
mentioned here we all know this
spaghetti Jupiter notebooks that you
need copy pasting and if you're it
starting if you're using the code from
more than one notebook you need to
package it in a source control
environment it will be it will make it
easier for you to test your code and
share it between other data scientists
so try to understand how you you get
your big how you can be a
better software engineer profiling your
code if you have like an algorithm to
transport 20 minutes and you're just
waiting or browsing I don't know
Facebook waiting for it to finish try to
make things a little bit faster
this is by the way a very interesting
link of how to do it for data scientist
automation is also a great a great way
to to save time although the xkcd comic
says otherwise
push enabling tools you come out of this
meetup you have many ideas you saw some
great stuff push it to your try to
promote it within your organization
create dashboards for non-technical
people to view the data and come up with
new ideas it really it is really a
worthwhile effort and the last thing I
would like to briefly talk about is
retrospective which is done in also
software engineering methodologies like
scrum and agile tech I suggest I I did
it myself tech last year of your project
in your workplace try to rate them as
low medium and high influence and try to
understand what what is what
so basically time time is up yeah just
even if you don't implement all of them
just take one or two and and you'll be
better off Thanks hey hi everybody
thanks for being here my name is Omri
alloush i am senior data scientist at
gone bio i also data science at Elon
University its Faculty of engineering
and today I want to show you how to
create beautiful interactive reports
automatically using HTML so the slide
contains shameless promotion because
we're hiring but I would use going as
this as a place for what I actually want
to present gone automatically records to
inscribes and analyzes b2b sales we try
to help sales people we better let
Saleen with giving actionable insights
and recommendations
okay yeah so let's let's just jump right
into things let's say we were asked to
create a report about the sale results
of our different clients we have many
clients and for each we want to show a
table with the performance of each of
their sales reps the contact information
of the sales app we also want to show
the revenues of the company by month and
by industry the problem is that we have
dozens of clients and we have to do that
repeatedly periodically that's a lot of
work okay
so even if we get a basic file with all
of our information okay
try to think what would be the best way
to actually create a report like that I
would argue that using a PowerPoint is
just not suitable for the task because
we'd have to manually create the
presentation the report for each company
doing a Jupiter notebook involves the
code inside that's not really something
you can send to people they have to have
a server it's not really very useful so
what I suggest is to use HTML I haven't
seen many people do that I think it's
highly effective in sharing these
reports basically hTML is a text format
that includes tags that browsers can
render and display we can create HTML
reports since there are text files
automatically it's very simple we can
include interactivity using javascript
very basic JavaScript we can style them
beautifully they're very easy to share
you just attach the file or put it
online even as I do here with the get up
pages for free they open on all devices
including on mobile phones
nobody has to install anything it just
works so let's see what we try to create
here and give a better insight into as
to how it works
okay so this is a pretty ugly I didn't
have time for a beautiful report that we
created for one company okay you can see
that we have a table showing the
different salespeople of this company we
can also sort according to the different
columns we can search and filter going
to different results we can paginate so
it's also basically easier we can get
more information about each of the
salespeople okay so for each one we have
the phone and email if we want that and
the results of the sales person we save
space but we also include the reports
for the performance by month or by
industry and all of that is created
automatically okay now I'm going to talk
really quickly because there's a lot to
feel in those just ten minutes that I
have but basically this is really from a
Jupiter notebook that I'm going to share
if you run the code it will generate the
report I'm just gonna quickly touch on
the main aspects of things okay you
don't have to do this step but you do
need to install pandas and ginger -
ginger - is a templating engine for
python basically it gets either a string
or a file that contains placeholders
instead of developers that instead of
the values that we want to use and we
compile this this template and render it
with the actual values the syntax is
very similar to Python we'll see it soon
it allows loops and conditionals works
very well with pandas dataframes and can
be extended so let's see a basic example
these are the top three sales people in
the world and we just passed those as as
a list okay
we define the template hill 8/3 means
the header we just reference one of
those we load the template form string
we landed it with our data and then we
display it as HTML and we actually get
the results now what I got here is an
HTML
of HTML that Jupiter the Jupiter knows
who can render one screen but that's
something that I can save to a file
sends a Samba someone and you be able to
see the people okay to style our report
we can use Twitter bootstrap it's a
framework developed by Twitter that
contains many different elements of HTML
it's very easy to style elements using
CSS it gives us the accordion that I've
shown here to the right it gives us the
division into two columns and many other
things like this layout for example that
I can dismiss if I want okay
the tables that I've shown and made it
interactive all we have to do is just
get it panda's data frame we can use
pattern funders to HTML function to save
it as an HTML table better use a
function that I created it's given here
and allows more control in the HTML over
the table if we had this snippet of code
below the table automatically becomes
interactive we can sort it we can filter
it we can paginate through the pages and
if you want to create actual reports
that we just imported relevant packages
will know the data and focus on just the
one company that we want we group our
sales information by the sales per
person the industry and the month with
simple goodbye function of pandas so we
create different data frames okay here
by industry and here by math we create
the bow chart just by using the pandas
plural function and we save it using
matplotlib savefig function to a file
then we can link in HTML to the file
itself using the image tag and the
source with the actual file name that we
saved
it's one option and you can see that we
will enter the file an alternative is to
use a base64 presentation off the image
inline the HTML as a text string save
the image itself we don't have to have a
different file this is a function that
does that okay you can see how the
beginning of the basics the first thing
looks like it's not very important if we
do this fing and then we pass our data
into the template so we can pass the
data frames that we created earlier we
can pass the string representations of
the images or the image filename and we
can even pass functions and use them
inside the template the syntax of Jinja
too is very similar to Python you can
see that we have a for loop here we go
over the cells people using it arrows of
pandas we can use conditionals for if we
can apply many other things basically
just to show the information here we'll
load the template from f5 so I have a
file with all of the things that are
included we render it with the data and
we save it to file it's just a simple
text file here and eventually we get a
report
well everybody there is forget the
Salesforce part of as part of our data
science team evening even the Tel Aviv
office a short lecture I'm going to talk
about the first part will be why's it
important to explain machine learning
models and not just I'd prediction and
the second part I will talk about how we
are we dealt with this problem in some
of our projects so imagine for a moment
that your salary your bonus your
compensation depends totally on a black
box that give you an upper how how good
will you feel about it so for us for
many of our customers this is not very
far away from the truth so in one of our
projects we have to provide the
likelihood for a deal to close sales
people our customers are compensated
based on the amount of delay our closing
so we want them to use this feature to
allow them to choose which deals they
should invest their time on and and if
they will invest their time on the wrong
deals that you might not get the bonus
they might get lower salary so obviously
there will be pissed so one of the
things that we encounter is that they
don't feel obviously they don't feel
confident enough just by a system that
give them a knocker now I have to say
that some some customers are okay with
that
some customers okay with the system they
just give them a magic number they don't
care how it work this lecture is not for
them but most customers are not like
that so one of the way we found out that
if we can provide some insights toward
how the system took the decision what
was the
important factors in taking this
decision it will make it will make our
customers trust the system or it will
easy the integration of the system in
the in the organization and there there
is also not necessarily a positive side
effect that they will want more control
so when you are telling the customer hey
I took this decision based on the fact
that I see the opportunity or the deal
is from certain geographical area many
times the customer will come to and say
hey don't use that field I know better
it's not relevant so you also need to
take this into account and so I hope I
gave you a clear reason why we have a
great motivation it right the good
explanation to our prediction and why by
prediction why it's vanishing this time
more important that than the prediction
itself so by the time we we started to
work on this project specifically we
already had a working model that gave us
that gave us the prediction against the
likelihood that's what there happened to
be a random forest that we trained and
we did what we usually do when we
encounter a new project we start out
with the simple simplest possible
solution we can think of and we decided
that we'll make it as complex as we need
to be so in this case what we decided is
the most natural approach we said hey a
random forest is composed of many trees
a tree is a relative easy model to
extract the decision from we just look
at the decision path we will look at how
much its feature contributed to the
information gained there or whatever
matrix we are using and we based on that
we will basically create a message it
say hey this feature with a very human
readable name with this value appearing
there
in this deal and based on that we think
it's more likely or less likely to close
so we did this and we try it out on in
on small number of customers in a pilot
obviously it worked but in a row quite
right as well as we can and do better so
the things we learn from this is that
it's what makes sense for us the data
scientist does not really make sense to
customers one of the things I can give
you an example let's say that certain
opportunity ulcery deal does not have a
geographical region a region so for me
it makes perfect sense as a feature but
when you display something like this to
a customer and say hey this deal is from
no geographical region then I think it's
less likely to close that's they don't
like it it doesn't make sense to them
they don't understand that there might
be an underlying process that because of
it doesn't have that feature another
problem we had is we had many highly
correlated feature so sometimes we had
to to translate each one of those
feature to a key factor or to
explanation and that could cause that
could cause some time for sort of
completing or duplicated messages so
obviously we realized em at the end of
the day we realize that our message was
not clear enough that it was not simple
enough for them and it didn't get the
job done so basically we realized we
can't use jestro feature as the
explanation we need to do something
better but we have a problem
and the problem is that in order to
provide a coherent message in Ori in
order to provide a good explanation we
need a simple model something which we
have high degree of control it is easy
to translate but on the other hand if we
want to keep a accuracy and it is
important for our customers we have to
go to the direction of more complex
model and use many features so we are
having
of tug-of-war which is even worse
because we like to use discriminative
model like trees which are legs less
clear to explain so we decided to split
say let's use two separate models one
model will be used for the prediction
and another model will be be used for
the explanation now there are some
advantages to this decision one of them
is that it allow us to freely change the
prediction model and use a number of
different prediction models with high
degree of the different degree of
precision at precision without needing
to change the underlying explanation
behind it so this is a great advantage
for us and it also allow us to get the
explain ability and accuracy without
without having trade-off now there is a
an issue here that you might get sort of
conflicting information between our
models because we are using two separate
ones so this time we try we started out
and we went very differently we talked
to customers we talked to internal sales
rep we talked to product manager and we
created a very big list of possible
explanation towards why a deal made and
might have highlight dude or low
likelihood to close we don't look at our
feature we only took it took explanation
or reason that we can actually justified
before way others and we decided to use
two models and we use random forest
because it's very similar to the
prediction model we also use a linear
regression because it's a relatively
simple model and the simpler the model
if it get the job done it's better and
now instead of craning those model to
actually give us the prediction we train
them to minimize the error against the
predictor this way you're actually
making the model correlate with a
predictor another thing I haven't
mentioned that you actually hand-built
the feature to justify the different
reason we have
and we actually had to build them
differently for random forests and
linear regression and we put eventually
we picked the linear regression and
stopped investing time where we don't
need to so that's that's it just about
the the tools using the same time yeah
so yeah so we are using a Jupiter
Jupiter notebook obviously with a scaler
and pandas we can use Park if we want to
what you're seeing here is actually a
graph of how the likelihood of
opportunity to close change across time
which is caused by changes to this
opportunity we are actually using a
widget with inside the Jupiter notebook
when we actually can search and browse
the different opportunity so we can
debug them and understand problems or
other things well here's another widget
we are using again I'm not showing you
the notebook but this is actually from a
notebook which we actually can put put
on opportunity look at look at the
different factors we have how much they
contributed etcetera etcetera so that's
that's it and thank you any questions
good evening my name is Liran Heyman I'm
a data scientist at Intuit into it is a
multinational FinTech company working in
the personal finance space and we are
also hiring and growing in AI and ml
Center in Israel if you want to talk
about it during the break tonight I will
be talking about balancing classes in
Python and I have two main things on the
agenda the first thing is just
explaining the motivation behind why we
sometimes will balance classes and
secondly showing or explaining a useful
Python library which is a bit less known
which can be useful in this space and if
you fall asleep in the next 10 minutes
you can just go to this link and there's
a lot of really good code and good
explanations there for what I'm going to
talk about so let's take a motivating
example outside of the finance space
just a simple like screen for cancer we
know that typically speaking most
most patients will be healthy so a lot
of models can just be your healthy you
don't have cancer your healthy or
healthy but that's a bit of a useless
model because we're missing the
interesting cases of patients who have
cancer sure don't worry I'm not going to
talk about what you're talking about
there's a there's a fallacy of accuracy
with them imbalance classes where the
minor class is interesting but it's not
being picked up by the model and we want
the model to hear the voice what I like
to say with the minor class and that's
why balancing classes meaning making the
minor class equal to the major class in
size it becomes really useful there are
two minor points I will raise here but
not discuss the effect of balancing
classes depends on the classification
model you end up using SVM decision tree
logistic regression etc there's no time
shield rather tonight and you can extend
what I will talk about beyond binary
classification cases just for simplicity
I will stick with binary classification
so let's map up the options where New
Balance classes on the left hand side of
this tree you have basic sampling
strategies which means let's stick to
the data that we have in the data set
and not create new fake data but either
over sample the minority class by just
like ctrl-c ctrl-v basically of right
around and data in the minority class or
under sample the majority class just
removing classes from the majority class
so what I have in the bottom left corner
is random sampling strategies which a
lot of us would intuitively suggest
which is what I just described which I
won't discuss because it's a bit less
interesting and it doesn't work so well
when you train a model so I will talk
about the green text over here the first
thing is Tomic links which is a
strategic way to decide which data
points to remove when you want to
understand for the majority class so
what is atomic link Tomic links are
defined by when a data points nearest
neighbor belongs to the other class or
another class and the idea with atomic
links is to remove if a point in the
minority class if its neighbor belongs
to the majority class we basically want
to remove
that point from the data set why do we
do this again like I said before we want
to hear the voice of the put of the
interesting cases in the minority class
so here we've got these blue points in
the minority class the black points
belong to the majority class but before
we train a model we remove these black
points from the data set again a lot of
you will ask are we cheating our goal
isn't to be um loyal to the data our
goal is to train a model that works and
that's why this is ok so that's why this
is ok so Tomic links are a really useful
pre-processing step in in the next steps
that i will talk about now it's not used
isolated generally speaking on the right
hand side of this tree you have a very
interesting strategies over here which
is what I call synthetic data generation
which means that the data that we end up
using in when we train the model doesn't
actually exist in real life we might be
using data points which we've created
from from thin air basically but it
works to train a model so it's ok so
here we have and this is the the Python
libraries called imbalance to learn you
just pip install it this is where you
have smart and add a sign and they're
really simple to implement I don't have
the code snippet here but it's very it's
a single line of quota imported and two
lines to run it smart stands for
synthetic minority over sampling
technique and out of science that stands
for adaptive synthetic I'll have time
tonight to talk about smote and its
variations so smoke the idea is as
follows when we want to over sample a
point from the minority class what we do
is instead of this ctrl-c ctrl-v that i
mentioned before just creating and
duplicating your new point what we do is
we find a point in the minority class we
find its nearest neighbors we say K
nearest neighbors K is usually five you
can play with that parameter that's K
nearest neighbors belonging to the
Minari class so we see these five blue
points over here we randomly pick one of
them and then instead of just control-c
control-v like i say one of those points
we choose around and point on the vector
which connects the two points and create
that new data point over there
so that will enter the model that big
blue dot over there but it doesn't
actually exist in this in real life but
it's good to train a model so here we
have an example of this in in um in
action on the top we have the original
data set and over here we have an
applicant and the blue class is the mine
miner class over here we have that it
being implemented and as you can see
that all these blue points over here in
that what's usually a wide space in the
UM in the original data set so we've
created these like synthetic data points
which don't really exist but it's good
for training a model there are two
disadvantages to this what vanilla
smooth the plane application of smoke
the first disadvantage is that we are
sorry sampling every point in the
minority class equally which isn't
necessarily what we want to do and I'll
explain why basically some points in the
minority class interests us more than
others points closer to the decision
boundary are much more important for the
model to hear its voice
so we might want to be re sampling those
points more than the points very safely
inside the region of the minority class
the second disadvantage is that we are
always restricted to the region of the
minority class meaning all these new
points that are created stay inside the
minority class and there's no real
reason for that restriction meaning we
could easily have new points outside of
this region and it could actually help
train a model better so there are two
variations to smoke both also in this
imbalance learn Python library which
solve each of these our Savannah jiz and
I'll start with borderline two and it'll
become clear in two minutes why start
with two or not one so two comes and
solves the solution of this issue of
having all the new data points being
restricted to the original region of the
of the data set and it does it by saying
that when we choose these K nearest
neighbors over here don't just take the
K nearest neighbors from the minority
class but you can even take the nearest
neighbors from the majority class as
well and by doing that you end up
getting new points outside of the region
of the minority class now
in order not to become too extreme and
just have this random daughter like into
like sparsely thrown out of the region
of the minority class we multiply this
by the small random Nam
close to 0.5 which basically allows a
point to still be closer to the minority
class but not restricted to the original
region so that's borderline 2 which
solves that disadvantage of having the
new points restricted to the region of
the minority class borderline one solves
this problem I mentioned before that all
points are resampled equally and it does
it in the following way it says let's
divide all the points of the minority
class into three cases the first case is
noise and this is where all of its
neighbors belong to the majority class
and the decision that they are guys to
develop borderline one came up with is
these are just outliers get rid of these
points you can argue about that claim
but that's what the algorithm does then
you have the safe set where the majority
of the neighbors belong to the minority
class those points we don't really want
to over sample because they there are
there already so safely embedded inside
the minority class so there's no
interesting resampling them what is
interesting to us please work is the
danger set where the majority but not
all of the neighbors belong to the
majority class and those points we
really honor resample so we will do
smoke but only on those points and this
is the results of borderline one as you
can see we've resampled a lot very close
to the decision boundary we haven't
resampled at all away from the decision
boundary that's borderline one a design
is basically the same as borderline one
it just has a slightly different
algorithm which i don't have time for so
this is the results of a design is
having the same the same solution where
the new data points from the minority
class are outside the original region of
the minority class and also what a
design does is says let's resample
proportional to the number of neighbors
that exist in the in the majority class
the more neighbors that the data point
has in the majority class the more we
want to resample that point in summary
the recipe for success use Tomic links
as a pre-processing step to remove
majority class data points we don't want
and don't use vanilla smoke for those to
just have our ninjas that are raised and
again if you fell asleep but it doesn't
look any of you did see that link thanks
and
so reword the question as a note that
perhaps removal of of points from the
using Tomic links is not a good idea
because you want those those data points
from majority class and you just want to
be resampling minority class points
close to that I fully agree
I recommend do it like every answer you
do both and compare your results you're
right sometimes it's not the right
solution I would say if you had to pick
one thing just remove them as a quick
solution did you get to use this in your
work I do get to use this in my work we
were predicting um overdraft incidents
of users who are spending their money in
the u.s. in the US you get a thirty four
dollar fee every time you like overdraft
your account which is insane and it's a
rare event as you can see it's not like
0.04 percent balancing also works if
you've got like a 14% class or 15
percent class what's nice these days
with computing powers you can always
just try something n compare results
when you said to connect the minority to
create synthetic minority class
connecting it on the majority class I
don't I don't understand the semantics
behind it and how you ensure like yes
this when you had this blue point inside
the majority class how you ensure that
you don't switch the semantics of your
synthetic data are you ensure that you
keep being minority every point has a
label so you still the label for that
point will usually yeah but though you
show you're not freaking you so you like
I said you are tricking your model but
the goal here is to train a model that
will end up predicting real data well so
I could train a model on numbers that I
invent in my head and if it has good
results I will use it this is a
philosophical question
I think it has results so it's
justifiable I think I think we're going
to the break time so